hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar the evolving role of
image-guided prostate cancer targeting
and appalachian moving towards
personalized medicine I am Judy your
work of lab roots and I'll be moderating
this session today's educational web
seminar is presented by lat roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning this
presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits if you
want to obtain the credits please click
on the get your free cm ECE credits
button located in the lower left of your
screen this will take you to the
continuing education page where you can
select a speaker click on the CEC Emmy
button and it will take you through the
process to obtain your certification
let's get started you can post questions
to the speakers during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the Q&A box
which will open when you click the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to get to
as many questions as we can and we'll
follow up if we don't have time today to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience any technical problems seeing
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speakers stacy lobe md
assistant professor of urology and
population health at the NYU School of
Medicine specializing in prostate cancer
ray ray Jean Gupta md assistant
professor of radiology director of the
abdominal imaging fellowship program at
the duke university school of medicine
and a faculty physician in the Duke
Cancer Institute and Thomas blaszczyk MD
professor of surgery director of the
Society of urologic oncology program and
director of the genitourinary program on
vocal therapy at the Duke Cancer
Institute
University Medical Center to learn more
about doctors lo Gupta and flossing
click on a still image in the right
corner for more information to go to the
lab root site dr. load will now begin
her presentation hi my name is dr. Stacy
low i'll be discussing trends and the
use of active surveillance for prostate
cancer patient selection and monitoring
prostate cancer screening has been an
issue of major controversy for the past
several years there are several proven
benefits to prostate cancer screening
including a reduction in metastatic
prostate cancer prostate cancer death
rates however there's also some harms
associated with screening the PSA blood
test which is used for screening is not
perfect leading to unnecessary biopsies
as well as overdiagnosis and
overtreatment of some insignificant
prostate cancers as a result of some of
these issues in 2012 the US Preventive
Services Task Force actually issued a
Grady recommendation against prostate
cancer screening with the PSA blood test
and the evidence they listed is that for
every 1,000 men screened there would be
one fewer prostate cancer death but many
more men with incontinence or erectile
dysfunction due to prostate cancer
treatment or other side effects of
treatment as you'll notice in this fox
though all of the side effects that
they're listing for the PSA blood test
are actually side effects of prostate
cancer treatment not of the actual PSA
test itself so my belief is let's not
throw out the baby with the bathwater
the PSA test has been shown to reduce
metastatic prostate cancer and prostate
cancer death but there are some negative
aspects as well which we need to deal
with including the false positive test
results and over diagnosed
and overtreatment so this is the
introduction to my talk which is
unactivated an important way to reduce
the burden of overdiagnosis because it
turns out actually that many low-risk
prostate cancers can be safely monitored
and don't need immediate treatment so
you can either delay or avoid all
together the need for aggressive
prostate cancer treatment and patients
with low risk disease this is a great
quote from dr. j smith from vanderbilt
treatment or non treatment decisions can
be made once a cancer is found but not
knowing about it in the first place
surely burns bridges so we do need
screaming still to diagnose the
high-risk cancers in time for cure
prostate cancer is the second leading
cause of death in the US but for those
men who do have a low breast cancer
there is no reason that it's necessary
to rush into immediate treatment the
problem is that active surveillance or
this approach of monitoring the cancer
conservatively was historically
underutilized in the United States as
you can see from these statistics up
until even 2009 across the United States
less than twenty percent of low-risk
patients were receiving active
surveillance but this had started to
change in fact there are a few recent
studies from different parts of the
United States showing forty to fifty
percent of low-risk patients now are
receiving active surveillance so
actually we're doing a much better job
of reducing the over treatment of
prostate cancer recent data from New
Hampshire in 2011 showed forty two
percent of low-risk patients getting
active surveillance in Michigan from
2012 to 2013 forty-nine percent of
low-risk patients received active
surveillance and in the US capture
database which is a nationwide database
40.4 percent of patients from 2010 2
2013 with low-risk prostate cancer were
receiving active surveillance these
trends have been seen in other countries
as well these are some
from Toronto Canada showing and the top
low risk disease and what you can see is
back in the 2002 2008 range more than
forty percent of all of this prostate
cancer surgery was for low-risk patients
and even as of 2012 this was down to
thirteen point six percent of the
prostatectomies only work for low-risk
disease so we are doing much for fewer
surgeries and much more active
surveillance now for low-risk prostate
cancer these trends have been seen in
many other countries around the world as
well in Australia from 2009 to 2013
thirty-seven percent of low-risk
patients received active surveillance
and in Sweden from two thousand seven to
two thousand eleven fifty-nine percent
of very low risk and forty-one percent
of low-risk cases were on active
surveillance so this is a great
improvement this is what I told Medscape
recently the era of active surveillance
for prostate cancer has arrived so some
of the initial concerns of the US
Preventive Services Task Force about
widespread over treatment of low-risk
prostate cancer really have improved
substantially over the past few years
now let's talk about what are the
objectives of active surveillance so our
goal is really to identify men with non
lethal prostate cancer who can delay or
avoid treatment and its associated
complications but nevertheless we still
want to monitor them we want to detect
progression if it occurs so that we can
offer treatment in Adelaide fashion but
still within the window of curability so
it is an active process designed to keep
tabs on what's happening with the cancer
traditionally the way that we've done
this is to continue to check the cancer
through two traditional test these
include the PSA blood test determining
what is the PSA level clinical stage or
the prostate digital
with a finger and looking at the biopsy
features the grade of the cancer which
is measured as the Gleason score and the
extent of the disease how much cancer is
there on biopsy so here's the issues as
I mentioned we do use PSA as a way to
monitor patients during active
surveillance the problem is the changes
in PSA during the course of surveillance
are not totally reliable we did a study
at Johns Hopkins looking at men they're
on active surveillance and overall at
three years thirty five percent of them
had biopsy reclassification meaning the
biopsy showed higher grade cancer or
more cancer but the problem is there was
no relationship between the changes in
PSA with the bad biopsy findings so we
concluded actually that just looking at
trends in PSA if not actually reliable
enough as a predictor of who has
progression during active surveillance
for prostate cancer so biopsies really
are necessary in order to check on the
cancer the problem is that biopsies are
an invasive procedure with potential
risks this is a study that we did in
patients from the USC or Medicare
database looking at manhole across the
United States more than 17,000 men who
had a prostate biopsy compare do
controls and as you can see there was an
increasing risk of complications over
time and men undergoing prostate biopsy
there's the concerns that we have about
prostate biopsies are this increase in
infection it can also have some other
minor side effects like some minor blood
in the urine blood from the rectum blood
and the scene in urinary symptoms can
occur these are usually transient but
you know the process can have some
discomfort and anxiety for the patient
the other problem with repeated prostate
biopsies is there is this controversial
association possibly with an increased
risk of a wreck
al dysfunction either due to some kind
of inflammation around the prostate from
putting needles in the area on multiple
occasions not all studies have borne
this out and it's really difficult to
study this but it is something that I
think is worth mentioning to patients
and of course people don't enjoy
undergoing repeated biopsy so it can be
a source of non-compliance where men may
not come back as they're supposed to to
check on the cancer because they don't
want to have another biopsy so these
traditional approaches of monitoring
patients during active surveillance
which I mentioned including the PSA
blood test the prostate exam and
prostate biopsies are not perfect just
having one of these tests doesn't
classify patients perfectly following
the changes in PSA over time is not
reliable and relying on biopsies
involves risk to the patient and
significant burden so all of this has
set the stage for a critical need for
better ways for us to actually do active
surveillance non-invasive ways to try to
monitor patients during active
surveillance so what are some of the new
testing options that we have in active
surveillance one of them is to use
imaging such as MRI as a way to check if
there is a significant cancer present
there's also some new marker tests that
have been studied in active surveillance
including the prostate health index
blood tests the PCA three urine tests
and some tissue tests called Polaris and
Oncotype DX these different types of
tests have been summarized in a couple
of papers if any of you may be
interested in more information this is a
systematic review of some of the
clinical variables and biomarkers that
are helpful in selection for active
surveillance and another systematic
review done by some colleagues about the
use of MRI and active surveillance both
of these companion papers in European
urology this past year so just to
summarize MRI is probably one of the
greatest advances that we've had an
stay cancer over the past few years and
is particularly useful in the setting of
helping to select patients for active
surveillance because it turns out that
if you see a suspicious tumor in the
prostate on an MRI there's a much
greater risk of having reclassification
on a repeat biopsy reclassification
meaning an increase in the grade of the
cancer or the extent of the cancer so 2
to 4 times greater risk so
reclassification risk can really be
predicted by MRI and in fact in the UK
it's even recommended that MRI should be
done before the patient confirms that
they want to do active surveillance as a
way to make sure that there isn't any
more aggressive disease present that
wasn't detected on the initial biopsy
MRI may also be useful in a serial
fashion for monitoring patients during
active surveillance as yet not a lot of
research has been published on this but
this is a very area active area of
investigation trying to figure out some
kind of consensus on what constitutes
progression on an MRI how much change in
the size of the tumor or what parameters
on the MRI tell us that the cancer is
progressing so I see this as something
that's likely to come to the 4th run in
the next few years much greater use of
MRI and much more evidence on how we can
use it as a way to monitor patients
instead of doing so many repeat biopsies
another test that's been studied in
active surveillance is the new marker
test a new blood test called the
prostate health index or by pH I this is
basically just like a new and improved
version of the PSA test it actually
includes the PSA test and two other sub
forms of PSA called free and pro PSA by
has been extensively studied in the
initial detection setting so for men who
are considering a prostate biopsy the
prostate health index is better than PSA
it actually does a better job predicting
who will have significant prostate
cancer biopsy and it was FDA approved in
2012 for that particular decision point
so just to explain this a little better
we've known now since the early 1990s
the PSA circulates in the body and
preform and complex to proteins so
that's the pie chart on the left but
what you've no net can see on the right
is that the free form actually is
comprised of several different isoforms
and so this has all been discovered more
recently in this particular form called
pro PSA is more specific for prostate
cancer so the goal of this prostate
health index is to combine all these
different types of PSA in a ratio to
determine whether the amount of each of
these is something that's concerning for
prostate cancer so this is what the
report looks like basically you get your
PSA the pro PSA and the free PSA the
three parts separately and then you get
a combined score that tells you the risk
of finding prostate cancer on the biopsy
and predicts the risk of aggressive
disease so this has been studied now in
a couple of active surveillance programs
and it's been shown that the prostate
health index at the beginning of
surveillance or during the course of
active surveillance predicts the risk of
progression during the course of
surveillance so this was found at Johns
Hopkins and later validated in a
Japanese active surveillance program so
now we do have this as a blood test eme
MRI as an imaging test as some other new
options it could be used to monitor
patients pca3 is a urine test this has
also been looked at in active
surveillance initially this was FDA
approved for men who don't have cancer
who had one negative biopsy to try to
predict the likelihood of finding
prostate cancer on repeat biopsy
unfortunately some studies have been
done looking at this pca3 urine test and
active surveillance and did not find a
better
it this is looked at in two different
active surveillance populations at Johns
Hopkins and in the canary program and
the PCA three urine tests did not
protect you and progression so so far
not such encouraging results on that end
there are also some tissue tests one of
them is called Pro lares this is a panel
of cell cycle progression genes you send
the biopsy tissue to the company and it
measures how much cell cycle progression
is happening to help stratify the risk
of recurrence and a prostate cancer
death so this is what the report comes
back looking like it tells you what the
10-year risk is of prostate cancer death
for that patient if they're managed
conservatively so if that number is very
high then probably this person would not
be a good candidate for active
surveillance whereas if it's very low
then they may want to consider starting
off with active surveillance a similar
test but using different genomic markers
is called Oncotype DX as with Polaris
you send the biopsy tissue to the
company and they check for a totally
different set of genes from four
pathways involved with prostate cancer
to predict the risk of adverse pathology
and as with pro lares this can help to
further risk classify patients beyond
those tests that I just mentioned the
PSA the digital prostate exam and the
Gleason score so this is what the report
looks like Barranco type DX it tells you
the risk that you will have favorable or
unfavorable pathology in this patient so
if this score shows that there's a great
chance that the pathology is favorable
than that patient may want to choose
active surveillance so a little bit of a
different type of reporting than pro
lares but both of them with the goal of
giving the patient more information to
help decide whether to have treatment or
not so in summary the era of active
surveillance has arrived it's really
increasing and used around the world for
low-risk prostate cancer patient
selection the
based on standard factors though has
been somewhat limited because looking at
changes in PSA isn't very reliable and
doing a lot of cereal prostate biopsies
has significant risks and burden so we
really do need better ways to select
patients and follow them without having
to do frequent prostate biopsy some of
the emerging options for this include
the MRI which has really improved a lot
over the past few years and the new
prostate health index blood tests so
hopefully some of these tests in the
future can be used in combination to try
to reduce our reliance on prostate
biopsy and this is a very active area of
research so I expected will continue to
get much better with the process of
active surveillance over the years to
come thank you very much
hi I'm Rajan Gupta from the department
of radiology at duke university medical
center and i'm happy to be here to talk
about the emerging roles for
multiparametric MRI in the setting of
prostate cancer so what I want to do
over the course of the next 15 to 20
minutes is talk about the diagnosis and
work up with prostate cancer with
multiparametric MRI talks about the
value multiparametric MRI and some key
clinical scenarios and then finally talk
about how to integrate mpm Ryan to focal
therapy specifically what the role of
multiparametric MRI is in the setting of
biopsy and treatment guidance as well as
in the follow-up of lesions after
treatment and finally really stressed
the importance of a strong radiology
neurology collaboration so anytime we're
doing cancer imaging the goal is to find
the tumor if we can differentiate
between indolent and aggressive disease
that's critical but it can be difficult
and I'll talk about the role of atc maps
in that setting once we find the tumor
we must stage the disease and MRI allows
us to do that and finally once we sages
the disease and we do the treatment
we've to detect recurrence both local
disease as well as metastatic disease in
regards to mr the strength of mr lies in
its superior soft tissue resolution with
the delineation of the different zones
of the prostate gland we also have added
on high quality functional imaging to
our high quality anatomic imaging and
I'll talk a little bit about that and
finally have been able to increase our
resolution using endorectal coils in
combination with phaser a body coils so
the workhorse sequence in MRI and
specifically multiparametric MRI is
t2-weighted images tumors are going to
appear low signal on the t2-weighted
images and that low signal comes from
desmoplastic reaction as well as
replacement of glandular tissue by tumor
the value of t1 weighted images really
lies in their detection of hemorrhage
and making sure that we don't call
hemorrhage as tumor so that's why
ideally we'd like to wait eight weeks
after the performance of a biopsy before
doing any prostate and pre MRI imaging
some of the other advantages of
t2-weighted images allow us to talk
about staging specifically extracapsular
in our extra prosthetic extension
involvement of the parry prostatic fat
involvement seminal vesicles which is
key to diagnosing t3b disease
involvement of the neural vascular
bundles and finally involvement of the
adjacent organs including the rectum and
the bladder in regards to functional
imaging I'd like to focus on three
different types of functional imaging
today the first of which is dynamic
contrast-enhanced MRI a concept of
dynamic contrast-enhanced MRI is that we
rely on the concept of angiogenesis and
tumor vascularity to help us determine
what is a suspicious lesion and this
increases specificity when combined with
the high quality anatomic teaching
weighted images the caveat is that some
of these tumors will not demonstrate
increased vascularity so we can't use
dynamic contrast-enhanced MRI or dce-mri
in isolation diffusion-weighted imaging
is the concept that tumors will have
decreased motion of water molecules in
part due to their increased cellularity
this is a technique that we use
throughout the body and have now been
able to use very effectively in the
setting of prostate cancer small lesions
can be problematic but
diffusion-weighted imaging is definitely
increasing in importance in high quality
multiparametric and the right the final
functional technology i'll talk about is
mr spectroscopy and this relies on the
premise that different tissues will
metabolize different cellular
metabolites in neither normal tissue or
in cancerous tissue so normal prostate
gland will have high citrate levels and
low choline levels while prostate
cancers will show up with low citrate
and high choline levels due to their
high cell turnover so now talking about
some key clinical scenario specifically
in the pre therapeutic setting the key
ones that will talk about today our
failure to diagnose and that's
specifically in the setting of anterior
cancers there's no question that
multiparametric MRI adds a lot of value
in the setting of anterior cancer
specifically in those were we've been
unable to diagnose them with
conventional methods active surveillance
candidacy is an extremely important one
in regard to both diagnosis as stacy
globe was talking about as well as in
the follow-up of these lesions and
finally focal therapy evaluation is
something that is critical and something
MRI can add a lot to pretreatment
planning is something we can add to as
well specifically in differentiating
between TTC and t3 a disease but the
first three is what we're really going
to focus
today so the first scenario the first
patient we'll talk about today is a
failure to diagnose this is a 59 year
old male with an increasing PSA rising
from approximately 4.6 in 2003 to 36.3
in 2013 this patients done everything
right he came and had four prior trust
gutted biopsies in 2003 7 8 and 11 all
of which were negative for malignancy so
48 kors all negative for malignancy
patient was worried and he presented to
Duke for a second opinion so these are
the images here that comprise our
multiparametric MRI and three Tesla
using en directo coil the t2-weighted
images on the top left the ADC images on
the top right and the perfusion maps on
the bottom and what we'll see here is
that there is a very large anterior
cancer identified that is t2 dark has
markedly restricted diffusion and highly
suspicious for fusion kinetics so this
is a huge tumor about a three and a half
CC tumor in about a 35 c sequin and we
asked ourselves how does something like
this get missed well in this
high-resolution sagittal t2-weighted
images we can really find out how this
gets missed using simply systematic
trust guided 12 core biopsy typical
biopsy throw approximately 1.8
centimeters from the anterior wall of
the rectum unfortunately this tumor is
approximately two point four centimeters
from the anterior wall director so with
systemic biopsy comes systematic error
in this is an area where MP MRI can be
extremely valuable the second scenario
we'll talk about is active surveillance
candidacy this is a patient who is 57
years old with a very different PSA
trajectory than our last patient 1.1 in
2004 23.2 and 2011 did have a prior
trust guided biopsy which showed five
out of 15 course positive for Gleason 6
tumor no Gleason four components on the
right presented to do for an MP MRI and
evaluation of being an active
surveillance candidate we see the axial
t2-weighted images on the top left the
ADC images on the top right and Colonel
t2-weighted images on the bottom to
articulate and really show well the
location of the tumor anterior right
peripheral zone with mildly restricted
diffusion and I feel like you can see
nicely on the bottom image that the
capsule or the thin black line overlying
this tumor is clearly intact so based on
this MRI we were able to say that this
lesion was in the
to read peripheral zone at the level of
the apex with restricted diffusion but
mildly restricted diffusion and really
nonspecific perfusion characteristics we
felt this representative Gleason 6 tumor
we felt confident calling there no
extracapsular or extra prosthetic
extension and based on this patient
underwent a transparent eel mapping
biopsy this did in fact confirmed that
he has three plus three equals six
adenocarcinoma in the area of suspicion
and the patient was placed on the pardon
tables based on the pardon tables they
were deemed to have an eighty-four
percent chance of what we can find
disease my contention is with a
high-quality MP MRI we can add that to
that and feel really comfortable this
patient does that Gordon can find
disease a one-percent chance of seminal
vesicle invasion which again we felt the
seminal vesicles were normal and a 0%
chance of lymph node involvement so
today this patients on an active
surveillance protocol and they're on so
with confidence both the patient as well
as the clinician the final sorry we're
going to talk about his vocal therapy
evaluation so this is a 61 year old male
with an increasing PSA from 4.5 to
almost nine and 2012 at a negative pca3
test in 2011 and had 12 to prior 12 core
biopsies all of which were negative for
malignancy most recently in 2010
presented to do for a multiparametric
MRI as well as for possible transfer
neil mapping biopsy as we take a look
here at the t2-weighted images the ADC
map and the perfusion map we can see
very clearly that there is a markedly
decreased area of signal intensity along
the left posterolateral peripherals own
global the mid web with markedly
restricted diffusion and highly
suspicious profusion kinetics based on
this we can feel pretty comfortable to
what we're dealing with here is the
index cancer based on the degree of
restricted diffusion we feel like we're
dealing with a high-grade cancer and
based on the degree of capsular contact
greater than a centimeter we can talk
about the possibility of microscopic
extracapsular extension so we felt that
this was a high-grade tumor we felt that
there was probable intracapsular
extension here and that's what we
interpreted the MRI is the patient did
undergo a transparent eel mapping biopsy
which confirmed that he did in fact have
an index cancer at the site of the MRI
suspicion this was created as a 4 plus 5
equals 9 adenocarcinoma and based on the
extracapsular extension and grade of
tumor at this time the patient was
deemed not to be a focal therapy can
and was weighing his options one of the
nice things about the radiology
neurology collaboration here is that
when Tom Palaszczuk my colleague from
neurology speaks next he'll give you a
little bit of follow-up on this patient
and some of the thought process as to
why we would do what we do in these
patients and how the MRI adds value to
the care of these patients so switching
gears a bit I want to talk about how you
integrate MP MRI into a vocal therapy
practice so first and foremost any time
we're talking about mu MP MRI in the
setting of vocal therapy we must
diagnose the cancer and characterize it
appropriately what does that require it
requires technically robust
multiparametric MRI high-quality images
it requires experience radiologists
there's been literature showing that the
value that comes from experience
genitourinary trained radiologists
definitely adds value to MP MRI
interpretation and ads accuracy and
finally some come some form of
structured reporting that allows us to
integrate effectively with our urology
colleagues and that's in a critical part
of successful integration of MDMA into
your practice how can you improve
integrate MP MRI into biopsy and
treatment well the first thing you can
do is do cognitive fusion cognitive
fusion simply refers to the notion of
taking the NP MRI results realizing
where the lesion might be and then
effectively aiming for those areas on
standard trust guided biopsy and a dish
inul way of doing this thing would be to
do a fusion biopsy and Mariah ultrasound
fusion biopsy using software for lesions
which kit is to be seen on trust I do
require a biopsy and also this has value
in the setting of targeted therapies
finally we can do mri-guided inboard
biopsies which are for typically going
to be lesions that are difficult on
trust or difficult on fusion and really
more of a final problem-solving tool and
maybe for patients who have had negative
press guided biopsies in the past but
certainly the tide is towards the fusion
techniques in the beginning and less
towards the end more biopsies at the end
so into practice building you have to
determine what is the best option for
your group we determined that for us the
best option is high-quality MRI
interpreted by the radiologist and then
MP MRI ultrasound fusion by the
urologists another option would be to do
some kind of em are guided prostate
biopsy or therapy by
neurology radiology or a combination of
both anytime you're talking about
practice building you have to think
about the financial considerations and I
think that some of the things you have
to think about it the capital
expenditure and the ongoing costs of the
fusion system Orion buyer inborn biopsy
you have to model the opportunity cost
and MRI scanners of doing biopsies as
compared to diagnostic scans you have to
think about what are the new hardware
and software availability that's out
there in the marketplace and finally
think about reimbursements as to how is
your time going to be reimbursed and
what is the most effective utilization
of your time as a clinician and as a
radiologist so I want to show an example
of an MP MRI ultrasound fusion biopsy
case right now this is a 66 year old
male with a PSA of 9.7 had no prior
trust gutted biopsies and presented to
do for MP MRI and possible targeted
biopsy well we're certainly seeing here
at Duke more often as the fif see naive
patient the patient who says well why
should I undergo 12 for random biopsy if
I can get an MRI first and then get a
targeted biopsy and it's a question that
we're faced with very often and this is
an example of one of those cases so the
patient under what the MRI you can see
in the top left corner t2-weighted
images ADC in the top right and dynamic
contrast-enhanced perfusion maps in the
bottom and what we can see here is an
area of erased charcoal or lost
glandular markings in the transition
zone anteriorly on the Left restricted
diffusion on the top right and
suspicious perfusion kinetics on the
bottom and we basically do in a city of
your situation like this is as the
radiologist we interpret the mr and then
we do pre biopsy planning we do 3d
segmentation maps of both the lesion as
well as the prostate gland these images
are then fed wirelessly into our system
our ultrasound MRI fusion system and
then it allows for biopsy and this is an
example of what that biopsy looks like
on the top we have real-time ultrasound
images on the bottom we have fused to
real-time MP MRI images and on the right
side of the screen what you see is a
depiction of where all the needles went
so about five or six core biopsies that
were systematic core biopsies as well as
three biopsies that went right through
the target as we look at the results we
felt that this was a very high suspicion
of Gleason 7 plus tumor on MP MRI based
on the imaging findings the fusion
FC confirm that this was in fact the
index cancer a 5 plus 4 equals 9 tumor
and so that's what we ended up seeing in
this case in regards to the role of
multiparametric MRI and vocal therapy
it's certainly been the subject of many
meetings including a meeting that Tom
plastic will speak about which is a
vocal therapy meeting that we hold here
in a combination of Duke USC and in the
Netherlands and when we need to really
agree upon is the optimal imaging
parameters and the key question that
arises is what should be the dominant
sequence that is utilized and I think
you have to make a decision on that
based on both the scenario that you're
using MP MRI for as well as the lesion
location we'll talk a little bit more
about that the next thing we have to
agree upon is what is the optimal
follow-up should it be biopsy should it
be MRI or should be a combination of
both and finally understanding how
follow-up may differ depending on the
type of therapy use what is going to be
the most sensitive technique for
detecting recurrence after cryoablation
after laser ablation after high food etc
so what I really want to focus on is
dominant sequence dependence depending
on the scenario or Legion localization
one of the good thing that's happened in
the past few months here is that pie
rads which is a structured reporting
scheme for prostate imaging has recently
been released and it's given us some
guidance about what dominant sequence
should be used depending on lesion
location as well as the scenario so in
the peripheral zone the dominant
sequence parameters should be
diffusion-weighted imaging in the
transition zone based on the types of
tumors that we see there t2 weighted
imaging should be the key sequence
parameter and finally in the setting of
recurrence dynamic contrast-enhanced
imaging should be the dominant sequence
so I'd like to show an example of the
role of dynamic contrast-enhanced
imaging in the setting of PSP see a
recurrence this is a 70 year old male
who has a Gleason stuff in prostate
cancer diagnosed in 2007 underwent a
radical prostatectomy in 2007 with
recent biochemical recurrence the PSA is
now 6.11 in 2011 the patient underwent
an MRI the abdomen pelvis simply looking
for lymphadenopathy it was negative and
presented to do for a second opinion as
the biochemical recurrence was certainly
very worrisome so as you take a look at
what a post prostatectomy bed looks like
we have the axial t2-weighted images
here in the ADC maps here and the first
thing we have to do a scar selves is do
we see any evidence
disease recurrence it's extremely
complicated area their fluid levels as
some hemorrhage all sorts of things that
are seen in that area what we really
need is a guide post to help us figure
out where is the tumor recurrence if
there is presence high-res version 2
gives us guidelines that pece would be
very helpful we used ECE in this
particular setting in which you can see
is a hot spot or area of suspicious
perfusion kinetics on the right side
near the vesicle urethral anastomosis
and as we take a look here we call the
1.2 centimeter lesion here highly
concerning for locally recurrent
carcinoma no lymphadenopathy but
certainly something very suspicious for
local recurrence as I mentioned the t2
weighted images and the ADC images were
difficult to evaluate but the dcu is
extremely helpful felt so confident this
patient underwent a subsequent biopsy in
this area and it showed recurrent
prostatic carcinoma so to summarize the
role of multiparametric MRI and the
detection of prostate cancer continues
to increase and its really the multi
parametric approach has led to that some
of the literature was talked about by
Stacey load the keys are local disease
detection staging of disease and distant
disease evaluation the concept of
integrating vocal therapy really
revolves around finding the disease and
determining what the best option for
your group is and finally there's no
question that there's an expanding role
of multiparametric MRI in this setting
and we're fortunate to be part of the
group that's helping to understand this
a little bit better I'd be remiss if I
didn't acknowledge our multidisciplinary
prostate team led by Tom Palaszczuk from
deep urology we've had great
collaboration with our biomedical
engineering colleagues our pathology
colleagues some residents that have come
through the department of radiology as
well as in the School of Medicine other
key contributors including our former
director of MRI as well as our chair the
culture foundation and the NIH which has
been very gracious and funding our
research so with that I'd like to thank
you very much for your attention thank
you dr. Gupta and now for dr. polysix
presentation
I've been tasked with speaking about the
integration of multiparametric MRI in
active surveillance and a focal therapy
paradigm I wanted to start with a visual
of what the problems are with the blind
trust biopsy technique and as you can
see the top screen here the needle
itself mrs. the tumor which is depicted
in red in the middle one the needle
happens to hit a tumor but it's the non
aggressive one this is leads to
underdiagnosis this patient may be
inappropriately put on active
surveillance and then the bottom one the
needle hits the tumor but does not
detect the most aggressive elements
again this patient may be
inappropriately put on a surveillance
program so the first thing is that we
need to improve the prostate biopsy as
was mentioned by our former Speaker we
do have a technique called the
transparent nail three-dimensional
mapping strategy and which is done in
the operating room it's done through a
grid and typically 50 to 80 biopsies are
taken it's the biopsy that most closely
matches and predicts final pathology but
it is morbid prostate cancer to date has
been the only solid major neoplasm does
not rely on image guided biopsy but
there are plenty of references now the
support image-guided approaches being
superior so with this new approach with
image guided biopsy two things are
needed first you need accurate imaging
and we all feel that with
multiparametric MRI we have this and
second you need a method of targeting
the lesion and that's called mr I trust
fusion where the MRI is merged with the
ultrasound approach
this approach can be used not only for
diagnosis but also later for targeted
therapy I wanted to mention a paper that
doctor Loeb had referenced this is from
Johns Hopkins they looked at 50 men on
active surveillance and got an MRI on
them and found that with an MRI that was
positive there was a 40-percent
reclassification rate every biopsy
compared to if the MRI was negative in
which case there's only a twelve percent
chance of reclassification so even
without using the MRI for targeted
biopsy MRI in and of itself adds value
you've seen these lesions before this is
what we call as a urologist the Dark
Side of the Moon tumor this is a tumor
that I don't think many urologists would
hit with a standard office biopsy as
you'd have to actually push the needle
all the way through the prostate in
order to detect it and this is what dr.
Gupta has shown already as you can see
here you'd have to push the needle to
point four centimeters into the prostate
there'd be no reason to do this unless
you had an MRI that showed suspicion now
again the other option is that you can
come from this direction here and place
your needles like this this is what's
called transparent kneel and we would
take typically take anywhere from 50 to
80 needle biopsies under the scrotum in
this dimension trying to find these
anterior tumors this is work done by my
colleague dr. Peter Pinto at the NIH
where he compared the 12 core standard
biopsy to the fusion biopsy and he
looked at the MRI liberal suspicions as
you can see from the bar graph on the
left if there's a low level of suspicion
it doesn't really matter if you're using
MRI fusion or not however when the
suspicion level increases as to moderate
or even high level the MRI fusion biopsy
is much more sound and practical this is
dr. Pinto and colleagues group at the
NIH reporting of their latest outcome
this is published in JAMA this past year
and these authors showed that's the
sensitivity of the fusion by technique
with seventy-seven percent now the
question is can we just do this fusion
biopsy and replace the 12 quart
conventional biopsy I don't think we're
quite there yet as you can see in the
top right when you combine fusion with
standard biopsy there's about an
eighty-five percent sensitivity so you
do get a little bit extra sensitivity
this is what it looks like from a
practical point of view you see here in
the top right photo I'm working the
ultrasound my hands on the on the
keyboard and to the left of that is a
separate devices or fusion system just
below my chin level is a radiofrequency
transmitter that can localize where the
needle is in space on the middle image
on the left you can see the ultrasound
image with the superimposed target and
then the bottom one on the left of
course is your MRI image so what it
looks like when you're doing this live
this is the screen we look at the bottom
image is our MRI and you can see our
superimposed target on the MRI and then
we translate that image to the real-time
ultrasound and we translate the target
so you can see the target superimposed
on the live ultrasound and then we would
do the biopsy based on the ultrasound so
the fusion biopsy and multiparametric
imaging has certain advantages of it in
hitting larger more aggressive tumors we
can also map these things in
three-dimensional space and go back for
follow-up biopsy planning we can go back
to the same area and I think that's
something that's new that we haven't
been able to do before at the Duke
Cancer Institute we also have an active
surveillance protocol as doctor Loeb has
described we try to monitor encourage
all men that we feel safe that have a
low-grade cancer to be monitored we're
even willing to take on some men with
low intermediate features if they agree
to follow our protocol as you can see
our protocol
was heavily mri-based we use MRI to
characterize the tumors and then we use
the MRI fusion technology to target them
so then the question is how do we
integrate multiparametric MRI in accra
surveillance follow-up well as doctor
Loeb has mentioned already active
surveillance also includes serial
biopsies once you're on the protocol at
Johns Hopkins they used to do these
yearly a memorial in New York they did
it every two to three years and in
Toronto perhaps every three to four
years the question arises then if MRI
can follow patients reliably and
confidentially can we use serial MRI and
targeted biopsies and replace the need
for serial biopsies this is a question
that many investigators are currently
addressing the secondary question is the
cost of these MRI scans as they are
quite costly in the US but less so in
Europe now with anything new or novel we
need to keep an open mind because it
challenges our traditional methods of
managing prostate cancer and I want to
spend a few minutes talking about vocals
therapy for many years we've had the
economy of no treatment as you can see
on the left and see that watching it
passively or actively with active
surveillance versus the radical
treatments we have on the right surgery
radiation hoagland brachytherapy cry out
there but the question is can focal
therapy come in and occupy the happy
middle now with focal therapy we have to
utilize a number of avenues to roll this
out safely we have a number of centers
throughout the world that are doing
clinical research on this this is a
systematic review that my group
comprised of an international panel
recently reviewed the literature focal
therapy comes in a variety of fashions I
just wanted to take a moment to explain
them the picture on the top right is
weird all started back in the early
2000s if we found the main
with one side of cancer cancer confined
to one lobe and what you see here is a
picture of the prostate which is right
here and then you have the urethra here
in the center separating right and left
sides and you can see in the red you
have the cancer and each of these yellow
dots on both sides represents the nerve
bundle so in this gentleman he had a
Hemi ablation a cancer on the one lobe
and we ablated the whole side then the
question arises coming oblate perhaps
three quarters of the gland you see in
the bottom left whereby we can almost
eliminate the entire thing and spear the
one nerve and then on the bottom right
as well how far can we really push the
envelope can we do 99% of the gland and
spear that nerve that's a great question
we haven't really been able to achieve
that from a practical point of view but
the way things are going right now is
what you've seen the top left which is
true focal image guided treatment
whereby we're only treating the tumor
with a margin around it to ensure that
we try to get all the cancer now the
flip side of all this is the active
surveillance part as we talked about
vocals a combination of treating the
known cancer and leaving the rest of the
gland alone so back to our model of the
Hemi ablation seen on the top right if
you have blade half the gland by
definition the other half sign after
surveillance three-quarters the bottom
left you voice recorders and you take a
25-percent risk for the other gland but
as you can see with the top left as you
get more targeted with your treatment
you put more of the gland on
surveillance and you take more potential
risk for recurrence so this is a cartoon
depicting the various forms of focal
therapy top left is hope near whole
gland the middle on the top is the hem
ablation the right is the three quarter
and then on the bottom three this is the
newer types of treatment we're talking
about the bottom left is treatment of
two tumors in different parts of the
prostate the bottom middle is what's
called quadrant ablation
and we're purposely treating the nerve
on that side and then the one on the
right is the anterior gland ablation and
you're leaving both nerve bundles so
patient selection has been a work that
people have been working on we've had a
number of consensus panels this is a
systematic review that my international
group has written on bottom line is
there's no consensus as of this
publication back in 2014 for the ideal
candidate earlier most studies presumed
unilateral disease as I mentioned we got
we moved beyond that we at that time
we're using the bigger 50 core mapping
biopsies and we were just beginning to
use MRI however a consensus in 2014 then
showed that we should as dr. Lopez
stated shy away from the low-risk
patient cuz they're better suited for
active surveillance we then focused on
the intermediate risk one the volumes
not a determined since we're only target
in a small area and we want the man to
benefit from this treatment by having a
life expectancy over ten years I wrote
this article with my colleague dr. clots
from Toronto who is a very strong
advocate for active surveillance and we
both agree that there still are low-risk
prostate cancer patients that could
benefit from focal therapy in the area
of active surveillance because the two
approaches indeed can complement one
another so going back to the original
prototype which is the Hemi ablation you
see here we're freezing these are ice
balls we're freezing half of the
prostate here's the ice balls we have
two cancer's located here and I wanted
to go over some of the results based on
that original prototype we can't really
follow the PSA because we know the PSA
drops by about eighty percent but it
doesn't really tell us very much so we
have to rely on biopsy and as you can
see these are small studies but five in
the literature and you look on the
column on the right we see a lesson five
percent failure rate on the treated
I and up to about a 12-percent
positivity on the untreated side which
is basically what we expect anyway in
terms of the complications not many
bowel problems zero the confidence is
upwards of a hundred percent and the
potency in these studies was between
seventeen ninety percent with about half
the men resorting to oral five
phosphodiesterase inhibitors this is a
study reported by douban looking at
focal Hemi ablation again they found in
their series a hundred percent
countenance eighty-six percent potency
and then they tried to do a matched pair
analysis to look for men who failed
focal therapy might need further
treatment and when they compared the
patients on when focal to a cohort
undergoing radical prostatectomy as you
can see here with the p-values it was
not statistically different this is a
study from the University College of
London group using high foo to treat
prostate cancer in a focal manner very
similar results the pad three continents
rate ninety-two percent the potency rate
seventy-seven percent overall this is a
recent report on targeted focal therapy
by david crawford he placed gold seed
targets into the prostate and then
targeted those he found that at one year
eighty percent of the biopsies were
negative and he reported no adverse
events no incontinence nor change in
their sexual function scores so you saw
the prior cartoon of Hemi ablation and
what we're doing now in 2015 and Beyond
is dialing back at our treatment so you
can see here we're not running the ice
all the way to the edge we're now
pushing that ice back further and only
treating a smaller area of the prostate
again this is the patient who has the
Dark Side of the Moon anterior to
and the question is what do we do with
him so you know I'm a surgeon a Duke and
maybe the answer is radical
prostatectomy but these patients they
want more of a guarantee regarding
continents and potency and what can we
offer them so this is a novel concept
this is an anterior zone cryosurgery for
this particular patient as you saw his
tumor was in the anterior zone here
we're running the ice down to here we're
getting nowhere near his nerve bundle on
the left and the right so this patient
has an ideal outcome in terms of potency
and continents so what is the role of
multiparametric MRI in a focal therapy
program again we turn towards a
consensus effort of international
experts comprising radiologists medical
oncologists urologist radiation doctors
and we have these reports we're now
focused on identifying the dominant or
the index lesion we're focused on
intermediate risk cancers for the most
part and MRI can help find these tumors
that are typically larger than 0.5 CCS
and as dr. Gupta has shown you a Gleason
grade of 7 or higher in other words
clinically significant disease [ __ ] I can
localize them characterize them and put
them in 3d space and then we can go back
and treat them the other thing as a
surgeon that I always want to know is
has the cancer escaped so I find it
important to know about extracapsular
extension or ECE this study looked at
patients who underwent surgery so we
know if there was extension outside the
capsule but they had a negative him MRI
and it showed that using the targeted
biopsy scheme that was statistically
significant for predicting extra capture
extension even in the face of a negative
MRI once again supporting the need for
both MRI and targeted boxing combination
you saw this patient earlier this is his
MRI when you look at this you say wow
this is a great candidate for focal
therapy I know where to draw my margins
I can
a quadrant ablation just like this and
that should be quite effective but in
fact as dr. Gupta mentioned we biopsied
this one and it's a high grade and we
try to do the right thing for the
patient so he opted not to go with focal
therapy and went with radical
prostatectomy so MRI can help both ways
and finding candidates and finding men
who are not candidates so what is the
role of MP MRI in focal therapy this is
again an international consensus panel
we should use MRIs the optimal imaging
modality for follow-up after focal
therapy the first one should be done at
six months and then imaging yearly
thereafter if possible so what are some
of the downsides as was mentioned MRI is
challenging it requires expertise and
people who do this all the time we still
need more information on
cost-effectiveness and finally as dr.
Gupta mentioned standardized reporting
is really key and we feel that we're
there now with the pie-rats system so
bringing it all together MP MRI improves
risk stratification for active
surveillance by clinically detecting
significant disease by directing
biopsies to the lesion of suspicion and
it is also integral to focal therapy by
identifying localizing index lesion and
for follow targeted biopsies of that
area we're still working on an
international collaborative group to
push the frontiers of focal therapy our
next meeting is going to be a Duke in
June 2016 this will be our ninth meeting
it's an international working group of
scientists clinicians radiologists
industry medical oncologists etc those
that are trying to make better
treatments for men with prostate cancer
I thank you for your attention
thanks to each of you for your
presentations a quick reminder for our
audience how to submit questions simply
type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
the speakers will answer as many
questions as time permits and will
follow up if we don't have time today
okay so we'll give you a few moments if
there are no questions I would like to
once again thank doctors Loeb Gupta and
pelagic for their presentations and ask
them if they have any final comments to
share with us today Judy thanks so much
um I think that you know one of the
final comments that make is that I think
it's very telling that today's
presentation had two urologists as a as
well as a radiologist and in the
presentation I think it really shows the
importance of the collaborative effort
between radiology neurology to make this
thing a very successful endeavor I'm
very lucky to have folks on my team like
Tom Palaszczuk who will make who support
them or MP MRI and really the role as it
continues to increase
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and just a quick
reminder if you wish to obtain credits
for today's session please click on me
get your free cm ECE credits button
located in the lower left of your screen
this will take you to the continuing
education page where you can select a
speaker click on the CEC any button and
be guided through the process to obtain
your certification this Web cast will be
off viewed on demand through March 30th
2016 lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye